palais royal elizabeth 2 les secrets
enfin dévoilée vous savez que la reine
n'a pas le droit de parler à la parole
donnée sur l'opinion à la paroisse de se
plaindre mais vaut bien que de temps en
temps elle dit des choses donc comment
elle lady elle ne les dit qu'avec des
objets qu avec des couleurs et ça c'est
assez passionnant et on a tout ça grâce
à mon petit guide to voilà l'occasion
des 70 ans que demain un demain dimanche
non c'est demain quel à 70 heures de
l'après 68 95
il va sans doute ans de règne de son
vivant on peut la saluer pour ça rien
son vivant elle bat le record
aujourd'hui c'est la reine qui a régné
le plus longtemps d'angleterre déjà
mais mais mais nous les français elle
n'a pas il faut quand en fait il
faudrait qu'elles tiennent encore 2 ans
et 3 mois et elle nous aura battu nous
puisque maintenant celui qui a vécu le
plus qui a régné le plus longtemps
histoire c'est 2014 donc nous les
français on est encore premier
[Applaudissements]
m'intéresse c'est effectivement comment
elles communiquent par exemple les
questions saxo machin en fait la reine
son métier c'est de ne pas parler wilson
ne sait pour qui le vote si elle a un
avis sur quoi que ce soit elle n'a pas
droit d'exprimer les là pour unir
l'angleterre c'est le royaume uni donc
unie autour d'elle elle est là son
métier c'est d'être vu donc il faut
qu'elle se montre tous les jours c'est à
dire que le 1er janvier on lui montre
son cas son agenda pour l'année elle a
en moyenne un engagement par jour il ya
encore dans le rapport à ce qu'avait
hugo vide par an c'est-à-dire qu'elle a
elle a fait 3 161
361 engagements c'est-à-dire qu'elle
doit aller voir des gens qui n'ont
certainement le pour la plupart du temps
aucun intérêt qui disent des trucs qui
ne qui ne l'intéressent pas mais elle
obligée de les saluer et leur poser
toujours la même question d'où venez
vous il fait beau aujourd'hui
hélas toujours un chapeau des gants les
gants et un chat et un sac à main on ne
la touche pas c'est une personne sacrée
on a touch pas bon alors le sac à main
et l'autre jour un petit sac à main avec
mélenchon il inspecte non il est sacré
en amont chun ou non elle a toujours dit
ça pour quoi quant à l'envoi des boys
quelqu'un qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle a
son petit sac à main le petit sac à main
c'est un message envoyé à tout son
entourage c'est à dire quand l'entretien
et qu'elle est elle en a marre elle
prend de sacs à main et elle le met de
l'autre côté ça veut dire venez danser
mais qui venaient le chercher quand l
étang privé privé et qu'elle n'a ni
gants ni sac à main elle à sa bague de
fiançailles et quand elle tourne sa
bague ça veut dire à me dire stop s'est
terminée après la reine d'angleterre a
depuis trente ans la même longueur de
jupe ces chaussures sont testés par une
femme avant pour que ce soit confortable
parce qu'elle est toujours debout c'est
son chapeau doit pas le polar hr matière
sont son chapeau d'opel trop large pour
qu'on puisse la voir de loin on ne l'a
jamais vu en pantalon il paraît que la
céleste et pour que ça ne lève jamais
vous aimez de la reine absolument
elle est toujours à des couleurs jaune
citron pour qu'on la voit de très très
très très très loin alors son agenda ça
n'aurait pas que et pas avec les
couleurs par exemple lorsqu'il ya eu le
sommet sur l'écologie elle ne doit pas
sa vie en vert pomme pour dire quand
même que elle était pour l'écologie et
contre trump quand elle est venue quand
elle est venue à toulouse en france à
des visites elle s'est habillée en
violet pour rendre hommage au pays pour
expliquer que le violet c'est la couleur
de toulouse c'est ça tous les matins la
reine d'angleterre ce fait c'est un rite
immuable tous les matins il se fait
réveiller par un de la cornemuse qui
jouant bach buckingham palace tous les
matins ouais ce qu'elle est reine
decosse ne lui dit quoi envoyer
envoyé un message à l'école ça
ensuite on lui donne son nom lui apporte
son journal elle adore les journaux
hippiques mais vous savez qu'une reine
d'angleterre on le fait dans les travaux
de maison on lui repasse au fer à
repasser les doigts pour pas qu'elle a
dans lequel et d'encre sur ses mains
mais ensuite elle pense aux mains dans
18 cm d'eau puisqu'elle avait l'habitude
pendant la guerre des restrictions et
elle dit moi il sait moi j'allais ont
commencé tout ça
qui criait pas je suis la reine de
mykonos on aurait pu les besoins de la
baleine c'est fascinant quand même
mais on puisse et
on a tu connais la reine ce qui est très
important à savoir ça qu'elle a une
formation militaire c'est aux militaires
de ce qu'il allait dire c'est qu'elle
est venue seringue et une fois c'est moi
dans ce
que te dire que je suis petite jupette
mais alors nickel côté doublé avec louis
vuitton lui lbm vlv
vente à l'amiable était inconnu
j'en ai mais habilement pour m établi à
toi moi mais c'est épuisant mais
j'aurais aimé laurent gbagbo merci
j'aurais aimé un super avant que
quelqu'un avec qui je t'aime bieber
justin bieber marcourt mouly
en tout cas si tu habites pas ton cousin
nom soit
rayé ma tante on a fini pour sa mère
c'est assez passionnant tout ce que tu
peux qu'est ce que je peux vous dire sur
la rénover le ter non elle n'a pas de
permis de conduire pas de passeport à la
papa me produire mais là le droit de
conduire
à séduire l'angleterre qui peut conduire
sans permis les conduire ce qu'elle
valait jean-michel quand il a perdu pour
alcoolisme mais c'est tout
je plaisante
merci dilemme pour ceux qu'ils aiment en
juin prochain ce sera les 70 ans de son
règne et ça va être une fête
extraordinaire à londres et dans
l'ancien un concours de gâteaux au coude
il y aura le plus grand critique du
grand public était venu en
parking nous ignorons pourquoi est-ce
que ça si ce n'a pas été viré parce que
c'est elle qui a sorti un bouquin et
celles qui donnent tous angela kelly lfa
bouquin elle n'a pas et elle travaille
plus avec elle elle crève la faim ou
qu'un wii fit longtemps avec elle quand
on travaille pour la en angleterre on a
un contrat de confiance on en parlera de
parler quand vous parlez vous êtes alors
en plus en plus elle considère comme
pour le coup j'ai commencé à les
revendre très très cher après en oeuvre
j'ai travaillé à buckingham palace elle
vous paye pas très bien elle est un peu
chiche son seul petit défaut
un jour cet automne écrit un bouquin sur
moi la côte opposera pure and one aucun
auteur heymans est possible